good afternoon and soon we'll be saying
good evening to europe on the first
exchange of live programs between the
television networks of the united states
and their affiliated stations and the
european broadcasting union that was cbs
news legend walter cronkite co-hosting a
landmark event that would make
telecommunications history
60 years ago today and for the first
time ever three u.s broadcast networks
and the cbc in canada beamed a live
program from the united states to europe
by way of telstar one the first
television broadcast satellite that
20-minute program was called simply
enough
america july 23
1962.
it was watched by millions of viewers
here in the u.s and in europe the
broadcast featured live images from
across the nation
including the mormon tabernacle choir
performing at mount rushmore a cubs
phillies game at wrigley field this
baseball game is being seen in europe
right now
over the telstar satellite
and from the white house then president
john f kennedy's weekly press conference
i understand that part of today's press
conference is being relayed by the
telestar communications satellite to
viewers across the atlantic and this is
another indication of the extraordinary
world in which we live
robert thompson is a professor of
television and popular culture at
syracuse university take us back to july
23rd 1962
just how groundbreaking was the telstar
one satellite at that time it was
groundbreaking the ability to send those
signals up there and get them back down
on another continent was really
very important and cutting edge the 170
pound telstar satellite was developed by
bell laboratories for att at a cost of
almost 60 million dollars that's about
600 million in today's money it was
launched by nasa but was actually
america's first privately sponsored
commercial space flight mission
decades before companies like spacex got
into the game and its spherical form
became a pop culture icon and maybe an
inspiration
that's no moon
it's a space station it's too big to be
a space station
for the first time i was a senior in
high school
and the first time i watched star wars
and saw the death star i thought wow
that looks a lot like telstar and death
star telstar they could be siblings of
course it's a rule in live tv that
things don't always go as planned and
the first transatlantic broadcast was no
exception
the french are ready and the program can
now start
eurovision we're now putting up our
statue of liberty in new york harbor on
the left side of our monitor if you'll
please put up your eiffel tower in paris
next to it
and there were a few other glitches but
the broadcast was seen as a great
success
[Music]
and two hours later the europeans
transmitted their own images back to us
i am standing 500 miles from sicily in
vienna here we are 60 years later what
is telstar's legacy it gave us a uh half
a century and more of being able to see
live stuff from all over the world as it
happened but strangely enough what
telstar did uh satellite communications
it was so revolutionary we're still
using it there's all kinds of satellites
orbiting all over uh the place now that
we use all the time
and a really fascinating footnote
because i'm such a sci-fi like lover is
that the idea of like beaming like waves
in space came from arthur c clarke who
is the author of 2001 2001 2010 so many
other great books but just the what what
your guy said innovation imagination so
important and ideas yeah so important to
getting us to that next step now we just
have to be able to beam ourselves i was
just thinking that yeah
daddy be married
gene roddenberry already thought about
it i like it all right